[Music]
thank you for joining us for now what
will be a relatively brief 10-minute
newscast governor sissel act delivering
the state of the state address tonight
and then of course denise the republican
rebuttal
yeah we listened to both both of them
spoke about the effects of covet 19 on
the pandemic
the economy schools all topics that both
speakers touched on tonight
the i-team's vanessa murphy also
listening along with us and joins us now
live
hi vanessa hi yeah the governor calls
nevada's economy the hardest hit due to
the kovit 19 pandemic since the state
relies
so heavily on tourism he's saying that
needs to change and it's time to bring
in
other industries and other jobs his plan
focuses on renewable energy
fast tracking infrastructure projects
and help for small businesses all of
this tying in with his focus of jobs
he wants to add 50 million dollars to a
fund for small businesses
since he says they account for almost
half of all jobs in the state
he's announcing 25 million to continue
construction at unlv's medical school
to help end the state's doctor shortage
and he wants to upgrade technology in
the state including the system used at
the department of employment training
and rehabilitation
also known as dieter the governor says
dieter could handle
its average 20 000 claims a week before
the pandemic
but that jumped to 370 000 claims which
the archaic system
just couldn't handle he also says nearly
one in four nevadans are on medicaid
another result of massive job losses in
a state which relies so heavily on one
industry again he says his focus is
bringing in other industries
and training nevadans for new
opportunities
we will support our current industries
like tourism while developing new
industries
embracing innovation workforce training
investing in infrastructure to create
more robust and sustainable
economy governor siselek also
reiterating he wants
students back in classrooms he says the
state has worked to
supply personal protective equipment and
rapid testing for
all school districts and teachers are
being prioritized
to get the kovid 19 vaccine and that was
another focus
of the governor's speech he says the
state's biggest challenge
is running the largest vaccination
campaign
in history he blamed the federal
government for a lack of resources and
coordination
but he says the state is ramping up
distribution efforts
and that is something we've heard from
many of our viewers about
frustration about why it's taking so
long
to get nevadans the vaccine when we know
there are doses
available also by the way republicans as
you mentioned
responded calling aspects of the
shutdown draconian
and saying that they'll introduce
legislation against
voter fraud reporting live vanessa
murphy 8 news now